مستشفى ناصر الذي تعرض لحصار دام ع ايام
مازال يستقبل الجرحى والاصابات في ظل نقص
في الكوادر الطبيه داخل اروقه هذا
المستشفى للتعاون مع هذه الاصابات خاصه ان
اعداد كبيره من هذه الاصابات تصل حالتها
حرجه جدا ندخل الى الى وحده الانعاش في
مستشفى ناصر كما تشاهدون حجم الاصابات
التي تصل الى داخل المستشفى وحالتها
الخطيره تحتاج الى عمليات سريعه جدا وفي
ظل نقص في الكادر يوجد نقص حاد في الكوادر
الطبيه وخصوصا الكوادر التخصصيه مثل جراحه
الاعصاب وجراحه العيون وجراحه المسالك
البوليه وجراحه الاوعيه الدمويه وجراحه
الاعصاب والعمود الفقري يصل لنا كثير من
الاصابات بهذه التخصصات ولا نستطيع اجراء
اي عمليات لهم وهذا هذا هذه التخصصات
محكوم عليها اي بالموت المحقق ان لم تجرى
لها بعض العمليات تعاونا مع مستشفى
الميدان الاردني وارسلنا لهم بعض الحالات
بمجاز فه ومخاطره بسياره الاسعاف وتم
التعامل مع حالات جراحه الاعصاب في مستشفى
الميدان الاردني وتم انقاذ حياتهم نعاني
وبشده من تكدس النفايات الطبيه وغير
الطبيه في ساحات المجمع وفي اقسام المجمع
مكان التجمع اصبح مكدس به النفات الطبيه
وغير الطبيه وتعبث به القطط والكلاب وهذا
ينذر بانتشار الاوبئه والامراض بين
النازحين وبين المرضى وبين الكوادر الطبيه
في المجمع دائما المطالبات مستمره من قبل
الكوادر الطبيه ومؤسسات الصحيه ايضا داخل
قطاع غزه بضروره التدخل العاجل من اجل
انقاذ هذا القطاع المهم والحيوي في قطاع
غزه من اجل تقديم الخدمه العلاجيه للجرحى
والمرضى في ظل عدوان اسرائيلي مستمر منذ
اكثر من 116
يوما اسماعيل ابو عمر قناه
الجزيره خان يونس